¿Sabes? Usualmente, cuando hablamos de un diagnóstico médico,
existe esta expectativa enorme de que todo funcione con una
precisión casi matemática.
Sí, como en la ingeniería.
Exacto. O sea, te rompes el brazo, te toman la radiografía, ves
esa línea blanca irregular atravesando el hueso y el médico simplemente la señala y
dice, bueno, ahí está el problema.
Claro, es un sistema binario. ¿Estás roto o no estás roto?
¿Estás sano o enfermo?
Y psicológicamente eso es súper reconfortante, tanto para nosotros de este lado del
escritorio como para quien recibe el diagnóstico.
Totalmente.
A todos nos gusta que las cosas sean visibles, cuantificables y fáciles de meter en
una cajita.
Pero, a ver, luego entras al mundo de los síntomas funcionales, y
específicamente en la gastroenterología.
Y de repente, digamos que esa máquina de rayos X metafórica
se descompone por completo.
Nos enfrentamos a un panorama que es, la verdad, bastante turbio.
Bastante. Y frustrante en el día a día.
Sí, y es justo por eso que hoy, en este análisis profundo, vamos a
sumergirnos directamente en la base de datos de medsemiotics-db,
porque nuestra misión hoy es tomar toda esta evidencia clínica
rigurosa y aplicarla a un escenario real.
Y ver qué pasa cuando la matemática detrás de nuestra certeza se desmorona un poco.
Exacto. Y para hacerlo súper dinámico, vamos a construir este análisis alrededor de
un caso clínico socrático.
La idea es que a medida que desglosamos el caso, planteemos estas disyuntivas
reales que surgen en la consulta.
Sí, para que quien nos escucha pueda ir procesando su propia respuesta mental,
¿verdad? Antes de que nosotros desmenucemos qué dice realmente la evidencia.
Esa es la idea. Así que vamos directo al caso.
Imagina este escenario. Tengo aquí el expediente de una paciente ficticia.
Es una mujer de 29 años y de profesión es contadora.
Es un perfil con mucho estrés potencial.
Y su motivo de consulta es dolor abdominal
cólico. Específicamente, ella lo localiza en el hemiabdomen inferior.
Pero este dolor no es nuevo.
Dice que aparece varios días por semana y ya lleva lidiando con él desde hace
ocho meses. Pero hay un dato clave en el
interrogatorio. El dolor mejora sistemáticamente después de evacuar.
Bueno, ese es un hallazgo cardinal.
Es algo que debemos clavar en la pizarra mental de inmediato.
La relación con la defecación es vital aquí.
Pero, ¿qué sabemos de la consistencia?
O sea, ¿cómo es su hábito intestinal?
Pues es un hábito completamente alternante.
Según el expediente, pasa por semanas de heces blandas y frecuentes, que si usamos
la escala de Bristol serían un tipo 6 o 7.
Y luego, sin previo aviso, pasa semanas de heces duras, un
Bristol 1 o 2. Y además de esto, refiere una distensión abdominal
bastante molesta.
Claro, la clásica hinchazón.
Ajá, que empeora progresivamente hacia el final del día y, curiosamente,
coincide de manera súper exacta con los cierres de mes en su trabajo.
Lo cual nos dibuja un mapa clarísimo del factor de estrés psicosocial.
Los cierres contables son periodos de altísima tensión.
Totalmente.
Ahora, para poder armar la hipótesis completa, necesitamos ver el otro lado de la
moneda.
¿Qué cosas no tiene la paciente?
Bueno, los negativos son muy limpios.
Y aquí es donde la cosa se pone interesante.
O sea, no ha visto sangre en las heces, no ha perdido peso, el
dolor jamás la despierta por la noche y no ha registrado episodios de fiebre.
Excelentes datos.
Sí, y tampoco hay antecedentes familiares de cáncer colorrectal, ni de enfermedad
celíaca, ni de enfermedad inflamatoria intestinal.
Perfecto. ¿Y la exploración física?
Todo normal. Sus signos vitales son completamente normales, su índice de masa
corporal es de 23 kilogramos por metro cuadrado y sus ciclos menstruales son
regulares.
El último fue hace exactamente dos semanas.
Bien, entonces, con este panorama sobre la mesa, llegamos al primer gran cruce de
caminos del caso. Y cualquiera que esté en la práctica clínica y escuche esto,
seguramente sentirá el impulso de armar un diagnóstico diferencial inmenso.
Oh, sí, 100%.
Ante un dolor crónico en una mujer tan joven, la mente clínica suele pensar, bueno,
¿será intestino irritable o será algo más siniestro que se me está escapando?
Exactamente. Y si te soy totalmente honesta, mi instinto primario,
y creo que el de la mayoría de quienes ejercemos, es ir a la segura.
O sea, la visión tradicional que nos han enseñado por décadas dicta que debemos
hacer un descarte exhaustivo.
Claro, el famoso diagnóstico por descarte.
Ajá, que es enfermedad celíaca, enfermedad inflamatoria intestinal,
intolerancia a la lactosa, colitis microscópica, incluso cosas
ginecológicas como la endometriosis.
Sí, la lista es larguísima.
Y el miedo a equivocarnos nos susurra al oído que lo más prudente es
descartar absolutamente todo esto primero, con laboratorios e imagen,
antes de, digamos, rendirnos y ponerle la etiqueta de síndrome de
intestino irritable.
Y justo aquí es donde la base de datos nos da la primera gran bofetada
metodológica del día. Porque esa noción de descartar todo para quedarse con lo
funcional es fundamentalmente incorrecta.
¿En serio?
Sí, y el síndrome de intestino irritable, según la evidencia más robusta que
tenemos en medsemiotics-db, no es un diagnóstico de exclusión.
A ver, un momento. Tengo que hacer de abogada del diablo aquí, porque
históricamente el intestino irritable es enseñado casi como el cesto de basura
de la gastroenterología, ¿no?
Así es como se enseñaba, sí.
O sea, si le haces todas las pruebas al paciente, no encuentras nada roto, nada
inflamado, nada sangrando, entonces, bueno, por descarte es intestino irritable.
Además, ponte en mis zapatos, si yo en la consulta diagnóstico intestino
irritable en la primera visita y resulta ser una enfermedad inflamatoria intestinal
incipiente que simplemente no quise investigar, la responsabilidad legal
y moral es completamente mía.
Entiendo el punto perfecto.
Entonces, ¿me estás diciendo que la evidencia me respalda si decido no hacerle una
superbatería de pruebas a esta mujer de 29 años?
Te respalda plenamente, siempre y cuando sepas leer el patrón, porque entiendo el
miedo a la responsabilidad, claro, pero la evidencia muestra que tratar al
intestino irritable como un diagnóstico de exclusión genera muchísimo más daño que
beneficio.
¿Por qué lo dices?
Porque someter a una paciente joven a una avalancha de estudios innecesarios
no solo dispara los costos médicos, sino que multiplica la ansiedad de la
paciente y eso perpetúa el ciclo cerebro-intestino que agrava los síntomas
iniciales.
Claro, la estresas más y le duele más.
Y lo más doloroso, desde el punto de vista verdaderamente científico,
es que hacer todo eso no mejora tu certeza diagnóstica.
El intestino irritable es un diagnóstico que se hace en positivo,
basado en un patrón de síntomas muy
característico. Haces el diagnóstico clínico primero y luego lo
complementas con muy pocas pruebas dirigidas.
Nunca es al revés.
Ok, ok.
Entonces, si le quitamos el peso a las pruebas de laboratorio iniciales,
pues la carga de la prueba recae 100% en la calidad de nuestro
interrogatorio.
Exactamente.
Si no estamos excluyendo lo malo, tenemos que estar matemáticamente seguros de lo
que sí estamos incluyendo. Y supongo que esto nos lleva a diseccionar el dolor
de nuestra paciente contadora.
Así es. Revisemos los hallazgos de nuevo.
Su dolor abdominal es recurrente.
Está atado directamente a la defecación y camina de la mano con estos cambios
en la frecuencia y la forma de las heces que mencionabas.
Y durante la exploración física solo encontramos una molestia leve al palpar
profundamente la fosa ilíaca izquierda.
No hay masas, no hay órganos agrandados, cero signos de irritación
peritoneal.
Lo cual encaja perfecto con la triada semiótica del intestino irritable, o sea,
relación con la defecación, cambio de frecuencia y cambio de consistencia.
¿Tal cual?
Ahora, a ver, si vamos a hacer este diagnóstico en positivo y confiar en él casi a
ciegas sin pedir 10 exámenes de sangre, yo esperaría que este
patrón de dolor tenga un poder estadístico monumental.
Claro, uno esperaría eso.
O sea, para justificar no pedir pruebas, quiero el número exacto.
Necesito un cociente de verosimilitud, un LR positivo,
altísimo, que me diga, no sé, la probabilidad de que esto sea
intestino irritable se multiplica por 10 con este dolor.
Y es fascinante que busques esa red de seguridad en los números porque justo aquí
es donde radica el gran misterio estadístico en medsemiotics-db.
¿A qué te refieres?
Para el hallazgo clínico específico de dolor abdominal en este contexto,
la base de datos no te da un número gigante.
De hecho, declara textualmente LR no medido.
No. ¿Cómo?
¿Me estás diciendo que el síntoma cardinal, la piedra angular de todo el
diagnóstico, no tiene un número validado que cuantifique su probabilidad?
Así es.
Pero eso no tiene sentido. O sea, ¿cómo construyes medicina basada en la
evidencia sin la evidencia numérica del síntoma principal?
Es que así es exactamente cómo funciona la evidencia cuando es estrictamente
rigurosa.
El síntoma orienta el cuadro, sin duda alguna.
De hecho, un dolor que no tiene ninguna relación con la defecación te obliga a
desechar el intestino irritable y buscar otra explicación.
Pero operativamente hablando, ¿no hay un cociente de
verosimilitud positivo publicado y validado prospectivamente para el dolor
abdominal general que confirme este diagnóstico?
Espera, ¿no hay ninguna cifra publicada sobre el dolor en toda la literatura
gastroenterológica?
Bueno, sí hay cifras, pero el tema es que hay que saber leerlas.
El único LR publicado sólidamente en este contexto proviene de un gran estudio del
2008 en la revista JAMA con más de 2,000 pacientes.
Ok, eso suena robusto.
Pero escucha bien la cifra. Es un LR negativo de 0.29,
con un intervalo de confianza del 95% que va de 0.12
a 0.72. Y el detalle súper crucial aquí
es que ese número de 0.29 corresponde exclusivamente a la
ausencia de dolor abdominal bajo.
Ah, ya veo. Entiendo la trampa matemática aquí.
O sea, un LR negativo de 0.29 es un número fuerte para
descartar algo.
Exacto.
Significa que si el paciente no tiene dolor abdominal bajo, la probabilidad de que
tenga intestino irritable cae drásticamente.
Sí, se desploma.
Pero la base de datos se niega a tomar ese número específico del dolor
bajo y pegárselo a la categoría general de dolor abdominal, solo
porque a nosotros nos resultaría conveniente para redondear el caso.
Leíste mi mente.
Es rigor epistemológico puro.
Está basado en el principio de parsimonia.
No podemos extrapolar un número de una subcategoría a un concepto
mucho más amplio. El dolor es el núcleo de los criterios de Roma IV, sí,
pero por sí solo la evidencia estricta nos dice que no cuantifica la probabilidad
con un número cerrado, que el clínico pueda simplemente meter en su calculadora
mental de probabilidades.
¡Qué fuerte! Bueno, esto nos empuja a buscar certeza en el otro síntoma
cardinal, el hábito intestinal de nuestra paciente, que recordemos
alterna entre la diarrea y el estreñimiento crónico.
Porque si el dolor general no tiene un número, seguramente los viajes al baño sí lo
tienen. O sea, ¿por qué es tan importante definir el hábito predominante y qué nos
dice la base de datos sobre su poder estadístico?
Bueno, la definición del hábito importa muchísimo, pero la respuesta tiene dos
vertientes muy distintas, una para el manejo del paciente como tal y otra para la
confirmación del diagnóstico.
Claro, porque desde la perspectiva del manejo en el consultorio, tipificar las
heces tiene todo el sentido del mundo.
El hábito predominante te define qué tipo de intestino irritable estamos
tratando y eso guía directamente lo que vamos a recetar a continuación.
Exactamente.
Por ejemplo, si la paciente tuviera un predominio de diarrea, la
evidencia te acorrala y te obliga a pensar en descartar patologías súper
específicas, como la enfermedad celíaca o la colitis microscópica.
Por eso usamos la escala de Bristol en la clínica.
No es lo mismo tratar a alguien con heces duras tipo 1 que a alguien con heces
acuosas tipo 7.
Totalmente de acuerdo. Pero si dejamos un momento de lado el manejo
y volvemos a la confirmación diagnóstica pura, nos estrellamos de nuevo contra el
mismo muro analítico.
No me digas que también dice LR no medido.
Sí, tal cual. Si buscas en la base de datos el síntoma de diarrea o el de
estreñimiento, ambos figuran con el estatus de LR no medido.
Increíble.
Describen perfectamente el cuadro clínico.
Y sabemos que se correlacionan maravillosamente con el tiempo de tránsito
intestinal anatómico.
Pero matemáticamente no confirman el diagnóstico por sí solos.
No tienen un cociente de verosimilitud que podamos usar como tal.
O sea que si damos un paso atrás y conectamos esto con el panorama general, la
situación es súper paradójica.
Estamos haciendo un diagnóstico en positivo, basándonos en síntomas clásicos que no
tienen un poder discriminativo medido matemáticamente.
Así de cruda es la realidad.
Entonces, lógicamente, si los síntomas de inclusión no tienen números
fuertes, la llave para separar un cuadro benigno de una enfermedad
orgánica grave tiene que estar escondida en el otro extremo de la balanza.
Y esa llave, sin duda alguna, son los signos de alarma, lo que nos introduce
directo al siguiente nivel de complejidad en este caso, la discriminación con
la evidencia y este enorme, pero enorme problema que tenemos con las banderas
rojas.
Porque si los síntomas no discriminan con números, asumimos que los signos de
alarma sí lo hacen.
Ajá, eso asumimos.
Pero a ver, ¿cómo trata realmente la base de datos a cosas tan dispares como la
anemia, la pérdida de peso inexplicable, la fiebre o la sangre en las heces?
Agárrate, porque aquí entramos de lleno al terreno de las contradicciones médicas.
A ver, a mí me gusta pensar en los signos de alarma de un paciente como si fueran
el sistema de seguridad de un gran edificio gubernamental.
Me gusta esa imagen.
Tienes, no sé, sensores de humo en el techo, detectores de movimiento en los
pasillos, cámaras de circuito cerrado en las puertas.
Y en nuestra mente clínica, asumimos que cualquier sensor que se active
va a encender exactamente la misma sirena ensordecedora en toda la
cuadra que grita, ¡alarma!
¡Hay una enfermedad orgánica!
¡Corran a investigar!
Es una analogía fantástica, pero tenemos que
expandirla para reflejar la realidad de la literatura, porque la evidencia nos
demuestra que no todos esos sensores fueron calibrados por el mismo fabricante,
ni tienen el mismo margen de error.
Claro.
Y aquí reside probablemente la mayor enseñanza de este análisis, sobre cómo es
verdaderamente la arquitectura de nuestra certeza médica.
Empecemos revisando los detectores de humo, la anemia y la pérdida de peso.
Uf, dos pesos pesados.
O sea, si una persona llega a tu consulta perdiendo kilos sin razón aparente y con
la hemoglobina por los suelos, el instinto de cualquier médico es encender todas
las luces de emergencia e iniciar una cacería de brujas diagnóstica buscando un
cáncer o una enfermedad inflamatoria severa.
Y ojo, es lo correcto clínicamente.
Ambas condiciones disparan automáticamente el estatus de signo de alarma.
Pero, y aquí viene el giro, cuando buscas el respaldo numérico en la base de datos,
te das cuenta de que estas alarmas están sostenidas mayormente por consenso.
Solo consenso.
Sí. Por ejemplo, una revisión sistemática de Park del año 2010 afirma de manera
categórica que tanto la anemia como la pérdida de peso tienen una muy buena
especificidad para detectar enfermedad orgánica.
Ok. Pero intuyo por tu tono que hay un problema con esa afirmación.
El problema es que Park no publica cifras duras en ese sentido.
Nada.
Nada. A lo largo de todo el artículo no vas a encontrar una sola sensibilidad,
ninguna especificidad exacta, ni un odds ratio, ni un
cociente de verosimilitud que le dé peso matemático a esa afirmación para este
contexto en específico. Por lo tanto, el estado oficial en la base es, otra vez, LR
no medido.
¡Wow!
Son alarmas sostenidas por el peso aplastante del consenso clínico, no por la
matemática.
¡Qué locura! O sea, confiamos nuestras decisiones, que a veces son de vida o
muerte, en esos signos. Y debemos hacerlo, por seguridad, claro.
Pero si escarbamos en los cimientos, están flotando en acuerdos de
expertos, no en tablas de probabilidad.
Es una píldora difícil de tragar, sí.
¿Y qué me dices de la fiebre? Porque, digamos, si esta paciente llegara con su
dolor abdominal crónico y de pronto, ¡pum!, tiene 39 grados de temperatura,
se activa la alarma de enfermedad orgánica.
Pues, curiosamente, la fiebre ni siquiera se incorpora como una relación
diagnóstica dentro del universo del intestino irritable en la base de datos.
Espera, ¿por qué? ¿Acaso una fiebre alta no es la definición máxima de una
bandera roja para descartar algo funcional?
Es que, plantearlo en esos términos es caer en una falacia lógica.
Piensa en la paciente de nuestro caso.
Si hoy presenta fiebre, eso no contradice mágicamente su diagnóstico de intestino
irritable de hace ocho meses.
Ah, claro.
Claro, simplemente te está diciendo que la fiebre pertenece a un territorio ajeno a
los trastornos funcionales. Te obliga a buscarle su propia explicación por
separado. O sea, quizá tiene una infección urinaria o un cuadro viral
sobreagregado, pero no te obliga a abandonar tu hipótesis inicial para explicar su
dolor crónico.
Claro, no borra el intestino irritable.
Exacto. Declarar la fiebre como un signo de exclusión para el intestino irritable
implicaría una relación mutuamente excluyente que fisiológicamente
simplemente no existe.
Tiene muchísimo sentido cuando lo pones así.
Un intestino irritable no te vuelve inmune a contraer una gripe o una
infección. Es brillante.
Ahora, a ver, si la anemia es consenso y la fiebre es una falacia de
exclusión, vamos con las cámaras de seguridad del edificio.
La sangre en las heces, la hematoquesia.
Aquí la evidencia sí tiene que ser irrefutable.
Sangre en el baño equivale a enfermedad orgánica, punto final.
Y aquí, lamentablemente, es donde las cámaras de seguridad entran
en cortocircuito. Y mira, este es el tipo de cosas que hace que profundizar en la
medicina basada en la evidencia sea tan, pero tan absorbente.
Cuando analizamos la hematoquesia, tenemos a dos fuentes del más alto nivel
académico chocando de frente a toda velocidad.
Uy, a ver, cuéntame de eso.
Por un lado, tenemos un estudio de Hammer del año 2004.
Y ojo, no es un artículo de opinión, es una regresión logística aplicada sobre
568 pacientes.
Un buen número.
Este estudio declara con muchísima firmeza que la sangre observada en el papel
higiénico o en el inodoro discrimina claramente a la enfermedad orgánica baja
frente al síndrome de intestino irritable.
Y aquí por fin nos regalan números.
Aleluya. ¿Qué números dan?
Reportan un odds ratio de 2.7, con un intervalo de confianza del 95%
que va de 1.4 a 5.1, y una P estadísticamente
significativa de 0.002.
Bueno, eso suena a caso cerrado.
Con esa P y ese odds ratio es innegable.
Suena a caso cerrado, hasta que entra al ring, nuevamente, la
revisión sistemática de Park de 2010.
Este metaanálisis revisa la literatura y concluye exactamente
lo contrario.
Lo contrario.
Al contrario, afirma que los signos de alarma clásicos como el sangrado rectal en
realidad aportan muy poco valor discriminativo para separar lo funcional
de lo orgánico en poblaciones generales.
A ver, a ver, ¿y cómo lidia una base de datos tan estricta como
medsemiotics-db con esta pelea de gigantes?
Tienes a un estudio dándote un odds ratio de 2.7 y a otro
diciéndote que el sangrado casi no importa.
Pues, ante la contradicción, la base aplica la navaja de
Ockham. Prefiere la parsimonia.
Decide no emitir una conclusión definitiva.
Se lava las manos, digamos.
Se niega a atribuirle al sangrado un poder discriminativo absoluto que no
consta de forma inequívoca en toda la literatura cruzada.
Y hay una razón técnica profunda para esto.
En el estudio de Hammer, un odds ratio derivado de una regresión logística
no significa nada en el vacío.
¿A qué te refieres con en el vacío?
Para que ese 2.7 sea válido en nuestra paciente, tendríamos que estar seguros de
que el modelo estadístico original
controló adecuadamente las covariables clave, como la edad de
inicio de los síntomas, el sexo del paciente o los criterios de Manning.
Como hay discordancia con Park, la base registra el conflicto y se abstiene de dar
un número mágico.
Claro.
Obviamente, en la práctica clínica, si un paciente sangra, lo estudias.
Eso es indudable.
Pero desde la epistemología médica rigurosa, el peso real del
síntoma está en debate.
En resumen, o sea, estamos construyendo un diagnóstico en positivo
apoyándonos en síntomas clásicos que no tienen un LR
medido.
Y al mismo tiempo, estamos descartando enfermedades catastróficas usando
banderas rojas que o bien se sostienen por puro consenso de expertos sin
cifras o se encuentran en el medio de un campo de batalla metodológico entre los
investigadores.
Es un resumen perfecto.
Y comprender eso es la verdadera madurez clínica.
Saber exactamente con cuánta certeza sabemos lo que creemos saber.
Lo cual nos trae de vuelta al mundo real, al consultorio, para
el movimiento final de este análisis.
Las decisiones.
Exacto. Tenemos que tomar decisiones sobre el cuerpo de nuestra contadora de 29
años.
Bueno, te actualizo con el caso.
Hemos recibido sus laboratorios iniciales básicos.
El hemograma es impecable.
La hemoglobina es perfecta, o sea, cero anemia.
La proteína C reactiva no muestra ningún signo de inflamación sistémica.
La serología para enfermedad celíaca volvió negativa.
Y lo más importante para el intestino, la calprotectina fecal está en niveles
completamente normales.
Perfecto. Con toda esta información alineada, llega el momento de definir la
conducta. ¿Qué hacemos a continuación?
Pues permíteme seguir jugando a la abogada del diablo un ratito más.
Esta mujer lleva ocho meses con dolor.
Su calidad de vida está afectada, se estresa cada fin de mes en el trabajo
y sufre. Ya le hicimos pruebas no invasivas y salieron normales.
¿No valdría la pena, digamos, casi por un tema de salud mental,
pedirle una colonoscopía para darle tranquilidad total?
Es una tentación enorme.
Claro, ya sabes, para que ambos, médico y paciente, puedan dormir en paz,
sabiendo que adentro todo está estructuralmente sano.
Es de las trampas más comunes en la gastroenterología hoy en día, y la
evidencia la rechaza con un no categórico.
Categórico.
Sí, indicar una colonoscopía aquí solo para calmar la ansiedad es
mala medicina.
Fijémonos en la demografía de nuestra paciente.
Tiene 29 años.
La base de datos, citando un masivo metanálisis de 2012, que
evaluó a más de 260,000 adultos, nos dice que la prevalencia del intestino
irritable disminuye drásticamente en los mayores de 50 años, con un odds ratio
de 0.75 frente a los menores de 50.
Ok, ok.
Nuestra paciente está exactamente en el grupo etario de máxima prevalencia.
Además, el simple factor demográfico de ser mujer le suma un odds ratio de
1.67 para padecer la enfermedad.
A lo que sumamos que, bueno, no tiene absolutamente ni un solo signo de alarma
documentado y su historial familiar está inmaculado.
Exactamente. La evidencia es estricta en esto.
La colonoscopía en este contexto se reserva exclusivamente para cuando hay banderas
rojas indiscutibles,
o cuando los síntomas de nueva aparición ocurren en pacientes que ya alcanzan la
edad de cribado para cáncer colorrectal, o bueno, cuando hay una carga genética
familiar demostrada.
Entiendo.
Someter a esta paciente joven a un procedimiento invasivo con sus
riesgos inherentes de perforación y sus costos asociados, buscando una enfermedad
que los números nos dicen que es altamente improbable, pues va en contra de las
guías clínicas fundamentadas.
Lo cual nos deja con el reto final, que es el acto de la comunicación.
Y me parece fascinante porque la forma en que le entregas el
diagnóstico a la paciente es una intervención terapéutica en sí misma.
Es vital.
Porque el peor error aquí sería decirle, bueno,
ya revisamos todos sus exámenes y no tiene nada grave, felicidades, está
usted sana, es solo estrés.
Uf, sí, eso es un desastre.
Porque la paciente no está sana, tiene dolor real y su calidad de vida está
mermada. Sentiría que la estamos ignorando o minimizando.
Validar el padecimiento es el primer paso del tratamiento.
Se le debe comunicar que tiene un diagnóstico clínico firmemente establecido, no la
ausencia de otra cosa.
Se le explica claramente que padece un trastorno de la interacción entre el
intestino y el cerebro.
Hay que darle nombre y apellido al problema.
Sí. Hay que enfatizar que es una condición real, que es crónica y benigna,
y que inherentemente va a tener fluctuaciones orgánicas, agudizándose en
periodos de tensión, como sus cierres de mes contables.
Y habiendo establecido esa relación de confianza, ¿cómo estructuramos el plan
inicial en la consulta? ¿Y qué cosas nos harían dar marcha atrás y
reconsiderar este diagnóstico en el futuro?
El manejo recomendado por la evidencia es decididamente multifactorial.
Si tuviéramos que usar fármacos sintomáticos, dependería de su hábito, claro.
Pero para esta etapa inicial, el énfasis recae con mucha más fuerza en el estilo de
vida. Arrancamos cimentando esa relación terapéutica que mencionaste.
Luego, indicamos intervenciones de primer nivel.
Fomento de la actividad física aeróbica, establecer una regularidad estricta en los
horarios de las comidas para no confundir al tránsito intestinal, y la introducción
de fibra soluble en la dieta.
¿Y el tema de la dieta? ¿Qué dice la evidencia?
Si notamos, a través del interrogatorio, que el dolor se dispara con ciertos
alimentos fermentables, la evidencia respalda probar una dieta baja en FODMAP,
aunque, ojo, idealmente debe ser supervisada por un profesional de la nutrición
para evitar deficiencias.
Todo esto mientras mantenemos un marco de seguridad activo, me imagino.
O sea, le damos el tratamiento, pero no bajamos la guardia permanentemente.
Solo reconsideraremos este diagnóstico funcional si en el
futuro aparece de la nada un signo de alarma validado, o si el patrón de
dolor y evacuación que lleva teniendo por ocho meses cambia de manera drástica, o
si hay un fracaso total y absoluto a múltiples líneas de tratamiento.
Ese es el algoritmo de seguridad perfecto.
Protege al paciente sin someterlo a intervenciones fútiles desde el día uno.
Llegamos al cierre de esta inmersión clínica.
Si la gente que nos está escuchando, que probablemente mañana estará sentada en un
consultorio frente a un paciente con un cuadro similar, debe llevarse un
solo mensaje conceptual de todo esto.
¿Cuál debería ser?
Yo estoy convencido de que el concepto fundamental es que el síndrome de
intestino irritable se diagnostica en positivo.
Es un salto de fe clínica, sí, pero basado en el reconocimiento de
un patrón rítmico de dolor, atado invariablemente a la defecación y a los
cambios del hábito intestinal.
Y sin la muleta de los números exactos.
Exacto. El clínico debe aprender a confiar en la robustez de ese patrón visual,
aprendiendo a tolerar la incomodidad intelectual de saber que, en las bases de
datos más estrictas, esos síntomas fundacionales no tienen un cociente de
verosimilitud matemático documentado que nos respalde con un numerito.
Es, en el fondo, una profunda lección de humildad científica, ¿no?
Lo que nosotros usamos a diario para excluir verdaderas catástrofes de salud,
nuestras adoradas banderas rojas, pues muchas veces no están respaldadas
por ecuaciones impecables, sino que se sostienen por el peso del
consenso de expertos o, peor aún, están atrapadas en debates sin resolver
entre fuentes bibliográficas opuestas, como vimos con el sangrado.
Entender la medicina basada en la evidencia no se trata simplemente de memorizar
calculadoras de riesgo o recitar números de estudios.
Se trata de comprender la compleja y a veces frágil arquitectura de
nuestra propia certeza.
Es un cierre poético y muy real.
Y justo sobre esa fragilidad quiero dejar sobre la mesa un último pensamiento
provocativo. Un verdadero dardo intelectual que la base de
datos expone y que la gastroenterología moderna aún no termina de resolver.
Volvamos a nuestra paciente de hoy.
Según lo que discutimos, ella cumple a la absoluta perfección con los criterios de
Roma IV.
Que son, a día de hoy, el estándar de oro innegable.
Es lo que se enseña en todas las facultades de medicina del continente.
Y sin embargo, resulta que si haces la revisión estricta en medsemiotics-db,
la validación matemática de los criterios de Roma IV simplemente no consta en
estas fuentes prospectivas específicas sobre pacientes derivados a estudio.
Me estás bromeando. ¿Roma IV no está validado matemáticamente ahí?
No, con un LR prospectivo sólido en esas poblaciones.
Y aquí es donde la paradoja te golpea fuerte.
Si escarbas en la literatura, te encuentras con herramientas diagnósticas muchísimo
más antiguas, que la práctica contemporánea casi ha olvidado por
completo, como los criterios de Kruis.
Pues resulta que los criterios de Kruis sí tienen
publicado un cociente de verosimilitud positivo medido, validado y
espectacularmente alto de 8.6, con un intervalo de
confianza del 95%, que va de 2.9 a 26.0.
¡Wow! Un LR de 8.6.
Así es. O sea, para ponerlo en perspectiva a la audiencia, un
LR mayor a 5 ya altera significativamente la probabilidad.
Un LR positivo de 8.6 es un monstruo
estadístico. Significa que si el paciente cumple los criterios de Kruis, la
probabilidad posprueba se dispara tan alto que podría sellar el
diagnóstico casi con los ojos cerrados, sin necesidad de tocar un solo tubo de
laboratorio.
Y no solo eso. Incluso si nos vamos a los viejos criterios de Roma I, que ya
nadie usa, también tienen un LR positivo medido de 4.8.
¡Qué locura! O sea, las herramientas viejas tienen mejores números
que las nuevas.
Exactamente. Y nos deja con esta reflexión incómoda, pero fascinante.
En nuestra práctica clínica de todos los días, defendemos y utilizamos a rajatabla
criterios y consensos modernos que consideramos dogmas inquebrantables.
Roma IV es la ley.
Pero cuando los pasamos por el filtro de la evidencia estadística más estricta y
matemática, resulta que la ciencia moderna aún no ha logrado estructurarlos ni
validarlos numéricamente con la misma fuerza contundente que tenían aquellas
herramientas clínicas que hoy, irónicamente, ya consideramos obsoletas.
Como decíamos al principio, como humanos, siempre vamos
a preferir que las cosas sean binarias.
Nos gustan los huesos rotos o sanos, como en una radiografía.
Nos encantan los LR de 8.6.
Nos dan paz mental.
Pero cuando los rayos X se apagan y los números nos abandonan, el
razonamiento clínico profundo y el entendimiento sincero de los límites de nuestra
propia evidencia es lo único que verdaderamente ilumina estas aguas
diagnósticas turbias.
Nos escuchamos en el próximo análisis profundo.